- I have to say this too because
I think this is incredible
and I don't know any other artist
that has accomplished this,
but this is another number one for you
and you have number ones
spanning seven decades.
(audience cheering)
No one will accomplish that.
- No, two of us have.
- Who? Are you gonna say band?
Don't say a band.
- It's a band.
- It doesn't count.
- Took four of them to be one of me.
(Kelly cheering)
(audience cheering)
- That's my favorite joke.
Exactly.
- The Rolling Stones and me.
- That's incredible!
- Right and I'm not in the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame.
(audience exclaiming)
- Wait!
Are you serious?
- You know what?
I wouldn't be in it now if
they gave me a million dollars.
- Are you serious?
- I'm not kidding you.
I was about to say something else.
- (beep) me.
- Yes, I was about to
say I'm not (beep) you.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- If you ever change your mind-
- I'm never gonna change my mind.
- I have things in my career-
- And they can like that when they just go
you know what themselves.
- Yeah, yeah.
(audience cheering)
- That is brand new information for me.
I'm just saying if you
ever happen to just get-
- [Cher] Also can I just
say one other thing?
- Okay.
I changed music forever with "Believe."
(audience cheering)
- You really did with that song.
You know what's so funny?
So lemme say one thing.
I feel like "DJ Play A Christmas-"
- Oh, I love this, let say one thing,
but then let me say one thing.
- Tag, you're it.
- Okay, no, but I feel
like that's how massive
and in pop culture and
everything and how it hit
and impacted the pop culture community,
how "Believe" did, I feel
like that's the same vibe
as "DJ Play A Christmas Song."
It's that same vibe,
no one has that sound.
I almost think if
somebody sent me that song
for my Christmas record, I was like,
"I don't know if I could pull this off.
"I don't know if this is me."
It's so you.
The sound is so Cher.
It's so incredible.
(audience cheering)
I love it so much.
So I kind of feel like it's the
same thing, the same impact.
Anyway, I could talk about you forever.